change lives change organizations
organizations change the world
good afternoon on behalf of the oral
history program of the GSB Library I'd
like to welcome you to today's event on
the history of venture capital education
at Stanford my name is Paul rice and
this is the second in the series of
events on the history of the Graduate
School of Business I'd like to take a
moment to recognize some people who
support made this event possible
Kathy long director of the GSB library
Sherrill or Lachlan of the Center for
entrepreneurial studies
Sharon marine and Andrew sharp of GSB
Development and Rafe Beck of GSB alumni
relations and a special thanks to
Professor Chuck Holloway for his
guidance and advice in organizing this
event just a reminder that this event is
being filmed now on to our panelists
we're fortunate to have a very
distinguished group today gentlemen who
have all been involved for many years in
teaching about venture capital at
Stanford starting the nearest to me on
the stage Peter Wendel founder and
managing director of Sierra ventures and
Stanford GSB lecture and course head of
entrepreneurship and venture capital
since 1991 pitch Johnson founder of
asset management company in lecture and
management at the GSB Charles Holloway
the Kleiner Perkins Caufield & Byers
professor of management emeritus at the
GSB who's kindly agreed to serve as our
moderator and John Glenn actually there
I think we're a little out of order
John Glenn founder and Managing Director
of Glenn Capital Management and lecturer
at the GSB this event will last one hour
there'll be an opportunity toward the
end for questions and answers
so please well welcome our panel today
thank you Paul
it's a pleasure to be here in a
particular pleasure for me to be here
with these three gentlemen who not only
have evolved created and evolved the
venture capital curriculum at the
Stanford Business School but they've
also been major players in the venture
capital community here in Silicon Valley
so we're gonna we're going to talk a
little bit about their personal
backgrounds and then we're going to talk
about the courses here at Stanford and
how they evolved a little bit about
their alums some of you out there may be
past participants in their classes and
something about the impact they might
have had on Silicon Valley so I want to
start with the personal backgrounds and
so I start with Peter and Peter just
just what led you to a career in venture
capital you you started off working as
actually a salesman for IBM that's
correct yeah my early career right out
of college was with IBM and I spent two
years at IBM and then had two years off
for good behavior to go back to business
school which I went to that other
Business School and then returned to IBM
for another five or six years and
although I wasn't an engineer by
background it was clear to me from my
work at IBM the tremendous impact this
was in the early mid-70s the tremendous
impact that technology was already
having on all aspects of business and
particularly the technology coming from
the west coast so in 1981 at the end of
1981 I was was approached by a couple of
wealthy families to ask if they would
they were interested in getting some of
their assets in the venture capital
realm of investment and they asked if I
would consider leaving IBM to form a
venture fund to do that so that really
took a lot of the risk out of it for me
because we had a ready source of capital
so I just thought it would be more fun
to kind of look for the next IBM's
rather than spend my career at a single
large employer so that's kind of how it
came to pass and you undergraduate was
at Princeton
yes we've actually served on the
trustees for ten years and been the
chair of the trustees and and so you
basically were an East Coast boy until
you became a venture capitalist well
when I came to California I knew about
two people here
fortuitously one of them was Scott cook
who we were fortunate to write a check
and back in and do it so Scott and I
were at Harvard at roughly the same time
so if you only had a very small rolodex
it was we're glad you came out well I'm
the rookie of the group here I'm sure
the veterans will pitch what about you
how did you distinguished career at
Stanford then a Harvard MBA and what
lured you into venture capital well a
short version is Palo Alto High School
class of 46 and I thought of myself
not primarily but heavily as an athlete
as a runner and track athlete so came
across the El Camino to run and study
and I also loved technology so I became
a mechanical engineering student and I
did pretty well in that did okay with my
running although not
not olympic-class like my Jordan said
you did alright Payton Jordan said you
did he was your coach yeah no he wasn't
my coach my coach was a guy named in
Jaguars but anyway I had it like
Stanford can do I had a good career in
both my engineering and running then I
applied to Stanford Business School in
Harvard Business School and interviewed
for both I got into Stanford I didn't
get into Harvard so I went back east to
running our national meet and I went up
to Boston and told the admissions
director that how could you pass me up I
got great grades I'm a nationally ranked
athlete and I want to go to here and and
I had made a mistake and told the
recruiting guy that named Saltonstall
that I want to go to business school to
find out what business was like because
I wasn't familiar with it at all
which is true I was a coach's son my
mother was an English teacher and I only
met businessmen more or less when I met
the parents of my fraternity brothers so
anyway they finally let me in when after
I pounded on his desk and finished up in
a couple years
I liked everybody and went in the Air
Force during the Korean War got out and
because I was fascinated by a job I had
in the summer working in a steel mill I
got a job with inland steel working in
the open heart of the shop and became a
foreman and later on an ultra Foreman
which means you run a bunch of furnaces
that was terribly exciting but more
important for the future I met Bill
Draper who was a Salesman here just got
out of Business School himself having
been in the military first so he moved
into company houses near each other and
I we became good family friends and he
became a Salesman for inland and I
eventually after some training became a
foreman later a assistant superintendent
of a shop so then bill came out and
joined his dad in 1958 in a pioneer
venture friend call Draper Gaither in
Anderson and in 1961 I came out for the
big game this is an audience I don't
have to explain what the big game is so
we cooked up a SBIC which is a deal
where if you put up some money of your
own you could borrow a lot of money
so in 1962 bill grape and I started
Draper and Johnson investment company
and did that for three years and there's
some really good deals cuz at the timing
was good Sara Hill bought our portfolio
bill went with them and I was gonna go
find a company and buy a company to to
run quasi husband her but I kept finding
deals to do so I became an independent
venture capitalist in the end and gave
my company its name in 1965 and I won't
go into a lot of detail but as of now
I'm a limited partner only and not a
general partner in our new fund so which
is the ninth fund that we've done so I
got into venture capital because I had a
good salary and I loved my job I
regretted leaving the open earth as much
as any decision I've ever made but I
knew working for a salary was different
from forming capital I also noticed in
the annual meeting of inland steel
company that grandchildren of the
founders had four hundred ninety six
thousand shares each I had an OPS on 42
shares so this isn't working right but I
did I did miss the open Arts I missed
the kind of men and women I worked with
but it's been a it was the timing was
good measure capital was building during
that period and it's changed a lot we
can talk about that later
so John University of Virginia to
Stanford Business School yes I grew up
in Virginia came out here in 1965 when I
graduated from law school went to work
for a large law firm in San Francisco
four years later figured I loved study
of law but the practice of law wasn't
the right fit for me and I had worked
for a senior partner in the law firm
that represented hewlett-packard which
was then a private company at that time
and also was on the board of Stanford so
through the work I did for him I had a
little bit of window very early days
what firm was that John mcCutchan Doyle
brown and Bob Brown I had a window on
what was going on in the early days of
the Silicon Valley development
so I went to the GS being graduated in
1970 I was probably an odd person my
class because I knew what I wanted to do
when I graduated before we started class
the first year there were then about 15
venture capital firms in the country
pitch was one of the leading venture
capitalists and frankly he was one of my
heroes
and still is for that matter so I left
the practice of law my mother never
understood why but became a venture
capitalist founded my own firm in 1975
and of an active investing in small
private technology companies ever since
oh thank you for that those very
colorful backgrounds and very different
paths to the venture community so so let
me just ask you just briefly so John's
starting with you how was the VC world
changed since 1970 it's when you started
your career right yes that's that's
exactly when I started I think the
amazing thing about the venture capital
business it used to be a very small
group of firms Boston few in New York
one or two in Chicago and then a
collection of individuals like pitch
that had their own firms but always
invested together as part of the local
technology group and it was then a club
we used to go up to monthly meetings for
the Western Association of venture
capitalists in San Francisco and all the
young guys would trade their best ideas
with their friends and invite each other
to take a look at the exciting companies
that we were looking at well that was
1970 I think was 1974 when the
Department of Labor ruled that it was
appropriate for pension funds to invest
in venture capital partnerships and
after that for the subsequent period of
time until the current time we really
saw an avalanche of money coming into
venture capital venture
Olsson asset class that's accepted by
institutional investors and huge
participation well that has brought many
many more individuals into the venture
business in the United States and other
parts of the world and a huge amount of
capital so today we have a pretty
impersonal business
we rarely share our deals with our best
friends and it's pretty darn competitive
but it's a great business and I think it
certainly works for the best interest of
the entrepreneurs were out there trying
to raise money but you know that's my
perspective which you've seen at all do
you agree with John essentially that
it's growing from little to big I don't
there's nothing to disagree with he's
quite factual with this report I would
say though my sharing your deals well I
don't think I should be his hero I have
a number of reasons that's true but I
won't go into them all in 62 there
already was such a busy three or four
firms there was Draper Gaither and
Anderson as I've already mentioned there
was a firm data science ventures this
that was back east all there was it
anyway we got we got together for lunch
or dinner I guess it was but once a
month and there was 12 members of this
sort of informal group and some were
doing more real estate but of the of the
twelve I'd say five guys or firms were
doing venture capital
it was quite cooperative everybody knew
everybody if you wanted into a deal you
simply had to call up somebody and if
you wanted partners in the deal you just
called them up and it was not
competitive because there was not so
much money in the business then as some
companies became very visibly successful
money came into the business people
formed limited partnerships which they
forget that Madison was and they had
outside money and became more and more
competitive as firms were competing not
just the do deals but to have success to
raise money I think that factor became
made it more competitive but the main
thing in later competitive was that as
tandem and other companies became better
known and were successful and including
maybe Genentech money just came into the
business people wanted to invest in
venture capital Peter had friends who
wanted to get into it pretty early on
anyway but it became a kind of a good
place to invest and became known it was
not it was not something that everybody
heard of and then it went pretty well
for a few years and then it kind of
faded away and there was a wonderful
cartoon in The New Yorker where these
two obviously prosperous old guys were
sitting in a club and one said Samuel
whatever happened to venture capital and
and that wasn't in the mid-80s when
there was kind of a low spot and but in
the end it was a necessary function in
our entrepreneurial society they have a
place where people who want to start a
company could go get enough money to get
going and then and then build their
companies and then get growth capital as
well so there was there was the early
stage capital it was a second round
often to get a part of in the
marketplace and then growth capital to
grow even though you were profitable you
didn't generate enough cash to grow as
quickly as they as you could the
evolution was sort of straightforward in
terms of entrepreneurs looking for money
and people looking for entrepreneurs for
a long time there was ups and downs when
stock market went down companies
couldn't go public and that certainly
was true earlier in this decade but the
emergence of the social networks the
social deals obviously like like
Facebook and Twitter sort of changed the
venture capital business as well as
changing the changing the way we do
things and Apple sort of Apple was not a
successful deal to start with it
struggled and struggled and was until
Steve Jobs came back and did it all over
again but
but the the modern the modern venture
capitalist has to be really on top of
these trends there's there's a lot of
money looking for for investments the
huge kinds of returns that occur when
within four or five years you can make a
hundred times your money as it's
happening in some cases so the the
fundamental business is the same you've
got to find some companies and have
entrepreneurs believe in you of at least
find you to to be successful and it
isn't quite it isn't very cooperative
among the firm's it's honest among the
firm's but they don't show each other
their deals they don't invite people
people back and forth that much but
right now though you've got to have
somebody who's in touch with the trends
and the use of communications devices
handhelds computers and that sort of
sort of stuff but there's no question
that were in a very vast revolution
going on involving the use of portable
computing and and it has changed our
business in the terms of the kind of
people who will be alert to those issues
I would say as a firm with old guys like
in their 40s in it we didn't properly
see the social networking deals in time
to really get involved in them but
that's true confessions maybe but I
think that's true and I think that some
people did however and there were there
were only investors in Facebook and
Twitter and those companies now but it's
just it wasn't us now we're we've got
some other things cooking but that that
those kinds of companies and the
rapidity with which technology and
markets are changing changed the
business
so Peter 1982 still a little bit
collegial and then moving up as they
said how do you keep how do you see this
evolution and how do you keep ciara
evolving with it yeah well 1982 our
first fund was a 16-1 660 million dollar
fund and the industry so 1982 when our
firm started
it was before cell phones before FedEx
we had fax but barely you're looking and
wrap around the drum and put on it yeah
you know so it was a very different time
but instead of cell phones we had what
at the time if you wanted the phone in
your car yet something called a radio
phone which was a big thing that sat in
the trunk a lot of people in the
construction industry had it because
they had to drive from job to job but
there were about maybe seven or eight of
us in the venture business who spent a
fair amount of money to get one of these
phones and one feature of a radio phone
is you can hear all the other
conversations and there's only nine of
them it was said there was three there's
three towers in the Bay Area of one in
San Jose one an open one in San
Francisco San Francisco each could
handle three phones I'm three
conversations simultaneously and
everyone could hear everyone else's
conversation so by definition it was a
bit collegial because UK and they did
the shrewder ones knew how to kind of
hyper deal through some conversation you
may or may not really be having with
your partner about it but I think if we
look at the change in growth of the
venture industry and particularly the
implications of that for our students
and for our work here at Stanford you
know as the size and scale of the
industry has grown so much as John and
pitch both said in the 1982 when we
raised Serra ventures one there were
about four billion dollars of new
commitments into the venture and
industry and last year when my younger
partners just closed did the first
closing of ceará ventures ten there was
about 20 billion give or take which was
a pretty measly year or I mean it wasn't
it was a quite low year there's been
years as high as a hundred million
hundred one hundred billion or 105
billion to go back to 99 2000 so ujuj
run-up in assets under management and in
some ways I think that's forced a
formalization of the business it is a
business
now it's not just two or three people
kind of sitting around playing their
hunches out on investments that's made
the industry I think more cognizant than
ever of looking for MBA trained students
who have some some formal financial
training what what hasn't changed is
that it's still a hundred percent
focused on innovation and I think
younger people in the firm tend to maybe
have some of the best ideas venture
capitalist with more experience have a
better sense of how to get a deal done
how to structure a deal and so forth but
in terms of where the innovation really
lies in the coming years during the
liquidity cycle of an investment younger
people who come into a venture firm
often have more of that DNA than older
people who are already there so there
continues to be an interest in younger
people coming into a firm nowadays the
National Venture Capital Association as
six or seven hundred member firms even
in 82 when Sierra was formed I think
there were about 130 firms at most so a
lot more opportunity it's a lot bigger
business and I guess the last thing that
strikes me in terms of changes is that
since it's now a factor in the financial
market it's not a huge factor even at 50
60 billion dollars here that's not a
huge factor but it's much more subject
to the cyclic al aliy of any financial
market any financial market as we teach
here is going to have periods of
cyclicality where it's an attractive
market capital runs in to much capital
comes in it becomes unattractive then
their capital flows subside and the same
has gone on in the venture industry and
that means that our students sometimes
are graduating during times of great
expansion sometimes not so and but it's
interesting that in our three
backgrounds all of us represent so much
of what's happening with our students
say whether it's
in England steal an idea people often
start their careers before they come to
the school here at larger places or
initially go to work at larger places
but quickly look around and say you know
I don't think as hard as it is to leave
my friends and my good colleagues this
pitch was saying I don't think this is
really what I want to do for my life and
that's kind of the decision three of us
made and I think it's very similar to
the students who come see me every week
and do want to talk about the other day
if the things always look more
interesting in the future that I look in
the current right well thank you and and
turn now to Stanford and the courses
that we have here I know that both Peter
and John were influenced coming to
Stanford by pitch and so let me start
with you pitch so what what brought you
to the Stanford Business School to begin
to teach and tell us a little bit about
that and then and as you see the
evolution of the course while you were
involved well I came here to the
Business School first they said Greg
Peterson a friend of mine who had been a
Sutter Hill I've got a different job and
was moving and he had been teaching the
formation of new ventures course through
the late 70s it had been been teaching
of entrepreneurship has gone way back at
Stanford under leadership but it was at
Frank Shallenberger
but Frank schellenberg Frank
Shallenberger yeah Frank Shallenberger
I don't even know how far back but way
back into into the probably in the 60s
and 70s but it was just an isolated
course and an interesting thing to study
entrepreneurship but not a sort of a big
thing as you'd call it now anyway this
was formation of new ventures not
venture capital but I'm gonna sort of
transition as I make sure the audience
understood what happened was that Greg
Peterson was teaching this course on
formation of new ventures and he said
could you fill in for me for a year
because I have to leave in a hurry and
so I went to see Jim Van Horn who was
the Dean in charge of that area and I
said I'd like to do this and
so Jim hired me actually so the first
year in 1979 I took over that course
without very little experience except
having gone to business school and her
letter and I used the old HBS and
Stanford cases but I felt I didn't like
the course that much myself it was kind
of set in the ways of the cases that had
been written so the second year because
I wanted to get the entrepreneurs
involved
I used the cases out of my own files
besides some lectures and tests there's
about fourteen sessions that I had so I
developed these cases I would take the
take the business plan out of my files
write a very clever very clever cover
letter on it to describe the situation
that the students should think about and
and I also gave the students the option
then of talking about it
as a entrepreneur and how they would
handle the situation or how would they
would handle if they had if they were a
venture capitalists and began look at it
I don't know why I did that except I
think several students asked about that
because they knew I was a venture
capitalist so as you might guess since
MBAs vastly preferred to judge rather
than be judged most of the people chose
the venture capital option I also in a
more formal moment think the market was
speaking there was an interest growing
in venture capital and students wanted
to study it so in the next year I did
the same thing and I don't know exactly
at the timing owner of gross but I got
here but it was in a year or two a very
able teacher from Harvard Business
School a lecturer I began teaching the
same course with the same name but
different content so Michael and of
course that I was doing I had a bunch of
cases with the entrepreneur being the
guest that day and you had to write a
business plan which I had inherited from
the course before me so we had okay we
had cases every day we had two midterms
one was quantitative about IRS and that
sort of thing and pricing deals and the
third
thing that was a written analysis of a
case which I felt so it was important
but there was such a strong interest in
it so when kids learned kids students
learned that they couldn't take both my
course which was still called the same
name for formation of adventures and
herbs course which was had the same
number even they thought well that's not
a good reason we can't take both our
different courses and people say but
they had the same number that didn't
wash so I changed the name of the course
that I was teaching to entrepreneurship
: formation of new ventures a venture
capital and and herbs course was
entrepreneurship : formation of new
ventures and they became separate
courses and they stayed separate and I
kept undoing it and adding different
cases and limiting some cases I added
two cases in first I had in a case with
a woman entrepreneur but the company
didn't make it and so I had a delegation
come up as you might expect after class
they couldn't we have a case in which
the woman entrepreneur makes it so then
I found one and the woman that makes the
Nancy's Nancy Mira made these little
quiches and build quite a good company
so she not only succeeded but she
brought quiches with her in her part of
the session so I became a little more
popular there for a little bit so I did
that and I really didn't change the
format much except I really believe that
the students the the course was full and
the complaints we got it was too hard
work and on top of all this we have to
write a business plan but I said yeah so
it was remained a popular course and so
then about I've been doing it I couldn't
travel during that period and I liked it
and it led to lots of other things I
wish I won't bother right now with other
than it led me into Eastern Europe for
because of my some of my writing and so
in 1990 I decided make it my last year
and Peter Wendel was there available I
guess I didn't actually make the contact
and peach taking that hook that course
to a whole new level
but at least the beginnings of the
course were in my era and I loved doing
it the students like the course cuz it
was full and highly rated and I feel I
feel good about having pips bet those
twelve years because I think it started
something quite useful well it really
did pitch and as you say it evolved from
general course and formation new
ventures to a venture capital course and
got it on the road to what it is now III
remember pitch very well because when I
was at associate dean one of the things
that I did periodically was give
feedback to the faculty into the
lectures although I really never gave
any feedback to the lectures except for
pitch every year pitch would come into
my office and demand that I take the
time to find it to get an evaluation and
give give to them and pitch I always
admired you for that you're the only
lecturer that ever did that that's new
news thank you yeah but the course was
more popular than the instructor I'll
say that because not true so so we know
a little bit about Peter got here but
John how did you get to Stanford well I
started pounding on my old professors
door Chuck Holloway and said look I've
got a little bit of experience I'd like
to give back some of it to our students
could I find a way of teach at Stanford
Business School Chuck was always polite
but I never got that positive answer
that there was an opportunity but one
day one day he told me that or Groesbeck
had taught a very very popular course
and there was so much demand that the
schools considering offering a second
section of formation of new ventures so
I teamed up with another gentleman and
he and I launched that course for a
couple of years
dick Allen who many of you know we
really enjoyed working together dick
committed from Southern California and
it was a bit cumbersome for him I think
so he finally turned it over to me I
took the course for a few years
and then with consultation with with
urban chuck I decided to launch another
section of the venture capital course
alongside Peters and so I in my 20 years
I tried to develop themes topics issues
that I thought were leading edge in the
entrepreneurial world for students to
discuss over that time we do developed
about 35 business school cases and I
would try to get the protagonists about
whom the case was written to come and
share their experience with the students
a couple women a couple of them were
people who failed that was probably the
hardest part the people who failed love
to come but they didn't want to really
be too explicit on why they thought they
failed fact after you heard their
explanation it was hard to recognize
that they failed so anyway we had a good
time the students have really evolved in
this school I I go back to my days here
as a student class of 1970 very few
people had any entrepreneurial interests
there are some people in the
entrepreneurial area now but not not at
the time of our graduation but today the
fervor spirit interest in being an
entrepreneur is very pervasive herthis
here at the GSB and I think and my 20
years of teaching I became even more
reinforced in that conclusion one we've
got super bright students and maybe it's
the Stanford culture and location that
attracts them but we have a lot of
really bright future entrepreneurs so
you know we had fun I've tried to teach
the course it was called venture capital
in the entrepreneurial world really
launching a company and building a
company from the standpoint of an
entrepreneur working with a venture
capitalist so I probably put a little
bit more venture capital spin on it than
some of the formation of new ventures
courses but thoroughly enjoyed it and
you know like pitch and Peter I never
stopped answering inquiries from former
students who either want to launch their
own business or transfer to a new
opportunity or talk about what's going
on in the world it's a very rewarding
experience and a wonderful pleasure an
opportunity to be exposed to so many
bright young men and women that are
going to do great things
one way in which the business school
changed when I got going you couldn't
get ahead in an academic career by being
a professor of entrepreneurship you had
to be a deep driller in finance
marketing you had to have a discipline
and entrepreneurship wasn't accepted it
was the interaction of many disciplines
but for reasons I don't fully understand
except tradition you couldn't get to get
a PhD in entrepreneurship
I believe that's changed now and I get a
questionnaires from PhD students who are
obviously studying entrepreneurship so
Chuck you can describe the pedagogy
better than I can but is it true that
it's now a legitimate subject it
certainly is a legitimate subject
there's that's a different question then
can you get a PhD in it so at the
Stanford Business School there are
people who write dissertations on
entrepreneurship but they still get this
they still get their degree in a
discipline although that's a it's a
minor variation so Peter how did we get
you attracted to the Stanford Business
School what is it that allowed us to
capture you when you were in the middle
of raising a family you if you read
Peters Vita you know he's got more
activities on it then you can actually
get on two pages single-spaced how do we
how do we capture you oh I got a rather
frantic phone call from Dean Roberts
saying that pitch had asked if he could
make his 12th year or his last year
teaching he was glad to continue to work
with students but didn't want the
overhead of running a course and getting
the syllabus together and everything and
would I consider getting involved I
should say at the time Stanford was a
large limit
partner of our firm so uh when a major
investor in your firm called to do
something you tend to be more enthused
but also we had cooperated Sierra
ventures let's see at the time I came
down here we were on I guess our fund
four and we had in our first four funds
we had cooperated with Harvard to write
quite a few cases because there wasn't a
load of back in the late 70s early you
know there wasn't a load of case
material about the venture capital
business and when some of those cases
were taught here I would come down as a
guest just like any of us John alluded
to the fact he had a lot of he has a lot
of guests and during the time he was
teaching her so I had aside from being
in the classroom as an MBA student I
came down and was involved in the
teaching of this actual sort of venture
capital related material and I so I
agreed when when Stanford called I went
down I think I met with you I met with a
number of people I was a fairly young
guy concerning the kind of the Giants I
was replacing I was a very young guy at
the time and so there were some
skepticism about that so they said well
when do you just do it for a year and
we'll all see how it goes I said that's
fine
not realizing that the first year is all
the work right you gotta pitch had left
the course in great shape and the Dean
said listen he said why don't you do
this for a year don't mess it up you
know pitch cuts things in a good place
and he said one or two things you might
do is you might try and talk more about
the business of venture capital pitches
work was about venture capitalists and
entrepreneurs trying to create value
together and but the deans at the time
were smart enough to see that adventure
was becoming a real industry so he said
maybe you could do some material about
where venture capitals get their money
how they
get their money how venture capitalists
are paid and I said oh my partners are
gonna love this but basically so the the
first step was to put a front end on the
course that set some context for all the
work that that pitch had there about
venture capitals and entrepreneurs doing
deals together and similar I think
probably to both John's experience and
pitches experience from the first year
forward it was clear that the students
were there because they wanted to learn
about the venture business but it was
more likely because they were going to
be consumers of venture capital rather
than that eighty kids these students in
the class wanted to be purveyors of
venture kappa be venture capitalists but
the students were smart enough to
realize gee if I'm going to get in a
relationship with this person and it's
gonna be a long-term relationship that's
going to affect how my venture goes if I
understand where do they get their money
from and how are they paid and and
what's on the dashboard of a venture
capitalists as he or she drives to work
every Monday morning getting ready for
their weekly partner meeting you know
that that could help me be a more
effective entrepreneur so I think the
fact that I had an existing relationship
with Stanford of a business nature that
also are firmly participated in creating
quite a few cases and I actually seen
them taught here and I had some sense of
what an exceptional place a business
school was those factors were all
important in in deciding - my wife's my
wife didn't think this was a great idea
she didn't think I needed another job
but she's even come around on that so
that's good so that's that's that's
that's interesting and you alluded to
the fact that that things have changed a
little bit in your course so why don't
you say a little more about that
Marissa's when Eric Schmidt who's a
Princeton classmate of yours I think I
went to Google you got him to come and
participate in your class I kept
thinking you gotta come and participate
in my class because I said Eric you're
not a venture capitalist you're
entrepreneur he said no no this is piss
with
with what Peter's doing and so tell us a
little bit about how you evolved it well
it's what what pitch was saying earlier
that that all of this case material is
best explored from the viewpoint of both
the venture capitalist and the
entrepreneur and over the years I had a
tenure-track member of the faculty who
is very interested in entrepreneurship
who sat in with me for a year or two and
helped and then about eight years ago I
approached Eric about his willingness to
to help with a part of the class and he
this year in 2012 he helped out in five
or six of the classes Andy Radcliffe was
another person who was going through a
transition out of benchmark and was
thinking of spending more time at the
school and I said gee why don't you come
and spend you know do a few classes with
Eric and I and see how you like it and
then he very quickly launched his own
course and I've also been able to get
about 22 or 23 venture capitalists to
each contribute five hours to the GSB
during winter quarter and the business
plan projects that pitch alluded to
their students still think it's too much
work and but we still have it as part of
the course and I match each team that's
writing a business plan with a venture
capitalist that has relevant domain
experience to the plan they're writing
and typically we have about 17 or 18
plans a year so if I have 23 24 VCS on
the bench I can make the best matches
and some of them don't match up in a
given year with the project but it's all
really about leveraging the fact that
Stanford is here in the heart of Silicon
Valley that Stanford is so well regarded
by so many people in the valley so
intertwined as we learned in the New
York are so intertwined with with the
valley that it's pretty easy to to
leverage our presence and to get others
to help and when you have an
experiential topic like venture capital
entrepreneurship which is we're an
academic institution but it's
an experiential topic really I've spent
a lot of time trying to leverage the
environment we're in so those have been
the main changes but it's basically a
Pitchess course with a little venture
capital industry front end three or four
classes and then even more involvement
although he had I'm sure you had Jimmy
trade big came when you did
tandem and you had Swenson come when you
did Jenna yeah you know a number of
classes Nancy came when you did Nancy
yeah all the classes were cases that
were venture capital deals and the
entrepreneur came I think what you added
of great importance was to study the
industry itself yeah we didn't really do
that we talked about that but we didn't
have a case about it or make it explicit
well there's been more of an industry to
study and so so I don't know what
they're doing back here but that's
alright whatever there's a big creating
something people generally mow lawns
outside the board meeting so so pitch
early on what you were doing was you
were bringing the Silicon Valley to your
class but in this in in the sense of
bringing entrepreneurs to the class John
what about you and in the way in which
you utilize our location here in Silicon
Valley how did that impact what you did
sure well the cases that I developed for
35 cases were primarily Silicon Valley
cases that I've had some relationship
with so it was pretty easy to get the
entrepreneur to come and share their
perspective with the students and you
know I look back very fondly on some of
those discussions I had one of the
Facebook guys come about I guess there's
about four years ago
the class ended at 12 o'clock no 12:30 I
couldn't get the students out the door
they were having some kind of a meeting
in there so some of them were extremely
popular and you know there was a real
animated dialogue among the students and
the guests but one of the things that
I've
in my experience teaching is that the
entrepreneurs in Silicon Valley and
particularly the GSB alumni are really
thrilled to have an invitation to come
back and share their experiences with
their students and you know that's what
it's all about thank you they want to
give back too so it's easy to get them
their schedules are a little tight once
in a while but I look back I think I
only had one or two cancellations and 20
years so I feel lucky but you know that
ambience that dialog among the students
and the entrepreneur was I think a fair
amount of their educational learning
experience that they got out of my
course so you mentioned the alums that
alums it came back and yes and of course
that's a reasonably significant subset
of the venture community so Peter did
you find that you were able to get the
Stanford alums more easily than you
could get Harvard alums or how did you
how did you see that evolution or that
interaction well first of all just to
share number of Stanford alums in the
area you know and it helps and certainly
the vast vast majority of the GSB
graduates feel great about the place and
you know as John said are just looking
for ways to be helpful where I think our
alums have been particularly helpful is
you know what's changed in particularly
the last 10 years is so many of the
students the MBA students come into the
course now already having substantial
background you know as pitch alluded to
and you know 25 years ago there wasn't a
ton of entrepreneurial background so if
you were teaching your class you could
pitch it at a fairly low common
denominator now you have some students
who have already worked at a venture
firm for a while or been successful
entrepreneurs before they even get here
and yet they're in a class with some
student from Chile who hasn't seen much
of the venture capitalist venture
capital model and you
need to somehow or other be relevant to
78 different students so having guests
who come and particularly guess just as
pitch did the course I teach from 10 to
11 45 and normally I can get the guests
to stay for lunch and then the students
that really want to get in as you said
have a special seminar job like they did
with Facebook you know I can
institutionalize that so every day
there's the class and then there's a
period afterward where and if the if
there's no guests at date and the
faculty just stayed for lunch and you
know Andy's a proud alumnus of the
school the classroom I taught him was a
Radcliffe classroom this year I felt
really good about that but it's not only
giving in a formal way but but just
being on call and being available
because so many of the students now are
so much further down the path that they
really you can do connections and link
people up in a way that that really
helps the educational process and maybe
even helps them professionally and our
alums are just really warm about that I
mean they just are looking for
opportunities to I mean we are we are
truly fortunate we're we exist here in
Silicon Valley pitch Peter mentioned
people students from Chile and others I
know you spent time in Eastern Europe
and say a little bit about what the
curriculum you taught here what part of
it might be relevant or irrelevant for
people around the world particularly
Eastern Eastern Europe the most of the
work I did in Eastern Europe was helping
establish venture funds there and
working with the venture fund managers
and developing some criteria and some
methods for running a venture firm in
the beginning in the early 90s there was
very little similarity because what was
happening there is most of those
countries were taking old socialist
companies we're getting brand-new
company
and starting companies to serve markets
they either weren't being served or
being served badly so that it was the
application of technology to normal
businesses that was what the business
was and not so much the development of
new technologies but it's still still
though it was finding marketplaces I
think the biggest thing in Eastern
Europe it's still a difficulty is
convincing people if the job of
entrepreneurs is not to have technology
but to think of markets and know about
technologies that conservative
marketplace or if they learn about the
technology first the next thought is who
wants this how can we what part of did
we put this in that will be useful to
other people
that is I went to a judge of venture
capital I should say entrepreneurial
contest in st. gears not too long ago
let's say 10 years and not one of the
entrance had mentioned marketing or
markets was all about the technology you
know what I wonder it was how difficult
the technology was to do so one quick
one had a vice president marketing and I
said well what is that job and he said
well it's to sell the products that we
make well that's a pretty good view of
marketing because marketing we now know
and they teach it here in Harvard to is
marketing is pricing distribution and
and most importantly it's the building
if marketers are involved in the design
of products from the beginning so the
thing is different there I I gave a talk
last October to 250 students studying
entrepreneurship in in Moscow so what I
said had nothing to do with any kind of
technology I said you can change your
country by being honest I said if you if
you go out there and refuse to deal with
people that want money for bribes or
that will better do what you know in
your heart is not honest stick with
those principles you can change your cut
really good it got a little publicity my
dad but and so there was lots of
questions but how can I do that if my
boss wants to do it how could I what if
other people make more money than I do I
said I'm just telling you if there's a
group you can sit together with a whole
generation of people operating in a
principled way and and building
companies based on honesty and
directness it's very important to it's
more important for you and your country
then whether you can make a few more
bucks doing something else and much more
importantly that it will define to
yourself who you are you you can look at
yourself say am I really the best person
I can be and I'm making my country
better and it was that was not a hundred
percent of dopplers by all the people
but there was a lot of skeptical
questions but then the sponsor of the
meeting russamano put it on their
website and so it's that's where the
publicity came it wasn't big publicity
by the way there's about as interested
you know look at the interest in this
seminar is about that level of interest
which we do want to ask you if you've
been invited back but I was invited back
this summer I couldn't go because of
getting some new knees but I mean your
question is teaching people
entrepreneurship in schools there
there's a much more fundamental job
you're teaching people to think about
marketplaces think about adapting
technologies to serve marketplaces and
running companies in a very
straightforward way the only the big
difference nowadays is we're still
operating on the front edge of
technologies and using things as in our
famous Facebook or Twitter and those
companies and there they have companies
like that but mostly they come up after
it's been done in the United States
or done in the Western world so I can't
answer a question except to say is
starting a company has many of the same
problems but they're serving different
marketplaces and they're a different
stage of development even now well thank
you that's very very interesting we've
got a few minutes left I've got more
questions but I wonder if there any
questions from the audience that
yeah John
so the question was if you didn't hear
it what's the implication of the venture
capital community moving around the
world so who wants to take that I'll
just take a quick answer first Europe
yes the the prevalence of the people
guiding the venture funds being started
in Eastern Europe or Americans so the
style of venture capital and the way
it's done in Eastern Europe that is
Poland and east of there it's quite
American the in Western Europe it's more
as more a banking of mentality you sit
in your office deals come you may take
off your coat in an emergency but it's
kind of a more of a financial operation
and there's a really fine venture funds
and there's one in Paris I'm close to in
several other places but we we make an
error when we try to translate what
we're doing here to someplace else I'm
sort of familiar with China I'm quite
familiar with Japan and I would say that
the model in Japan is so similar to ours
because there's lots of companies in
China I let somebody else talk about
China but I would say that the the main
problem is taking the principles of
venture capital where capital is looking
for an assisting companies that are
started to succeed and that fundamental
is there but the question of what
companies can succeed what markets they
can serve very so you got to be very
careful about trying to take the model
that we see within 50 miles of here and
say that can work in and especially in
Europe or in Asia so China Peter if your
firms never done any expansion overseas
we haven't expanded but we made a couple
of investments I would say my perception
is that over the last 10 or 15 years
there's been a tremendous push to have
international exposure by us-based
venture capital firms again in my
opinion the jury's still out
on whether that has been a successful
effort for the limited partners of the
funds there's been a few successes and
quite a few failures
I think people going over there those
that make it are successful in hiring
nationals to work in their office people
that understand the local culture
regulations patent law whatever have you
it's very hard for an American to go
over there and be successful as a
venture capitalist I I think the
cultural particular in Asia I think the
cultural differences are dramatic and
you know we know a little bit about
venture capital but our pattern
recognition skills are honed in a
completely different culture here the
notion that failure is okay is something
that's a cornerstone of the success of
Silicon Valley in many parts of the
world
failure is not okay and the ability of
people to take the kind of risk that you
need to take to launch a new product to
build a successful company you know is
hampered by that fear of failure so I'm
not convinced that the American model is
transportable I think many of the new
opportunities that are launched as new
companies in China and parts of Asia are
basically copies of what was done in the
United States so the formula is there we
know how to do it here it's translating
to a different culture that presents the
challenges for us you would have us here
yeah I just make three quick
observations first with regard to here
at the GSB this was the first year were
half of the students in 354 were either
born outside the US or had a degree from
outside the u.s. they're very interested
in the question you ask because they're
taking a course in American
Capital to figure out how they can bring
a lot of at home and how they can bring
that growth and prosperity to their
lands of origin so it's it's and I'm
sure in the students report here you've
seen the same thing with regard to
Sierra we've had a pretty good luck in
India and China a we have a firm in each
of those venues that we are partnered
with we have provided capital to them
we've helped them raise money local
partners yes right in both China and
India of the investing professionals at
Sierra now half are either Indian or
Chinese
in fact we're in the minority
no actually so that gives you some sense
of a local network and what the values
are and who went to school with who and
all the things that make us venture
industry go around but I think the last
thing I'd say is one of the difficulties
of transporting the u.s. model outside
of the US is that the venture model fits
in part of the overall capital food
chain there's angels before and there's
take out options afterward and
particularly up until five or ten years
ago in most countries outside the US
there wasn't something like the Nasdaq
you know so if you had about a five to
eight your hold period on these
investments and it had to be liquid
enough that it would be able to become a
publicly traded company in the country
where you were you couldn't start at
birth you know venture capital was more
like kind of merchant capital because
they would start with a company that was
already there and then try to move it
along because they only have a certain
period of time before your investors
require you to get liquid so it's it's
part of a broader food chain that that's
been one of the struggles - well thank
you very much panel it's been wonderful
to hear your perspectives on the venture
capital and particularly the venture
capital courses and how they've evolved
here at Stanford so thank you for coming